given how important it is
to be properly loved by one's parents in
order to have an emotionally sane
grown-up life one may wonder with some
urgency why
in cases that range from the regrettable
to the truly tragic
the process can go so wrong why do some
parents
who might in other areas be decent and
thoughtful characters
fail so badly at being able to love the
small people they have brought into the
world
among the many possibilities two stand
out in particular
the first stems from one of the most
obvious and unavoidable features of
early childhood
an infant arrives on earth in an
entirely and almost shockingly
vulnerable state
it cannot move its own head it is
utterly reliant on others
it has no understanding of any of its
organs it is in a penumbra of chaos and
mystery
in such helpless circumstances it must
look up to others and beseech them for
their mercy
it must ask them to bring it nourishment
to stroke its head
to bathe its limbs to comfort it after a
feed
to make sense of its fury and sadness
to most people all this is just
extremely sweet
but in order to take care of a very
small person an
adult is forced to undertake a very
particular kind of emotional maneuver
one which happens so intuitively and
speedily in most of us
we tend not to even notice it unfolding
we are required to access our own
memories of ourselves
at whatever age our young and tender
child happens to be
in order that we can more precisely
deliver to it the care and attention it
needs
most adults have no problem connecting
with the child version of ourselves
but this ability is far from natural or
spontaneous
it is a function of health and a
consequence of a degree of emotional
privilege
for a more disadvantaged sort of parent
however
unbeknownst to themselves the task of
care via identification
is overwhelmingly challenging somewhere
in themselves a wall has been built
many meters thick and topped with razor
wire between their child and adult
selves
something in their childhoods was so
difficult they do not
and cannot return their imaginatively
perhaps there was a parent who died
or who touched them in a way they
shouldn't or who left them bereft and
humiliated
things in their childhoods were
uncomfortable to such an extent
that their whole adult identities have
been founded on a thorough refusal
ever to re-encounter the helplessness
and vulnerability of their early years
they won't be able to be patient with
the little one's clumsiness and
confusion
they will have no interest in playing
with teddies they will think it pathetic
how tearful their child has become
because a four-leaf clover got crumpled
or a favorite book has a tear in it
they may despite themselves end up
saying don't be so silly
or even stop being so childish
there can follow a second characteristic
and associated failing in a parent
unresolved envy however peculiar it can
sound
a parent may envy its own child for the
possibility that it might have a better
childhood than they had
and will unconsciously ensure that it
won't
though ostensibly committed to the care
of the child the parent will struggle
against an
impulse to inflict against it some of
the very same obstacles
that they faced the same neglect the
same
uncaring school the same lack of help
with their development
the outward details may have changed but
the emotional impact will be the same
a new generation will suffer afresh
in order to parent properly not only do
we need to access our memories of our
own childhoods
we need to be able to come to terms with
our deprivations
so as not to feel jealous of those who
might have a chance
not to endure comparable ones in turn
but a certain kind of traumatized parent
remains at some level
identified in their minds as a needy
disappointed child
who would find it unbearable that
another child had more than they did
they are like a tormented and tormenting
sibling in a disadvantaged household
who takes out their pain on someone more
helpless scrupulously making sure
that the other child is as sad and
lacking as they are
we cannot help having had the childhoods
we had but if we are planning to have a
child we have a supreme responsibility
to ensure we have a sane relationship to
our own pasts
able to access them for reserves of
tenderness and empathy
and able not to feel envious of those
who do not have to partake in their
sufferings
we will be properly grown up when we are
in a position to give our offspring
the childhood we deserved not the
childhood we had
connect is a card game to foster
connection and closeness
with 100 questions that help couples to
rekindle affection